alright guys bangbang super excited to
have Jeff here thanks for doing this man
plump great Spanish oh absolutely let's
uh let's tart with your background
obviously you've you spent a bunch of
time covering various industries but
kind of where'd you grow up and what you
do before you get too fortunate I grew
up in Vancouver Canada used to be a
lawyer my joke was a got tired of being
unpopular so I picked the only
profession maybe less popular than
lawyers as a journalist but I know it's
been fun I've been at fortune for five
years also worked at Reuters and I've
written for most major publications I
got into crypto it's a fun story in um
2013 in New York City in Union Square
there's a thing for a while called
Satoshi Square where it was crazy it was
like crypto anarchists and say you know
old-school Bitcoin folks and then Wall
Street traders would meet up and
basically sell Bitcoin like in the open
air with stacks of Benjamins and I want
to cover that and that kind of wetted my
interest in it never since then I've
been covering crypto on and off you know
of course like you know if there's a
peaks in the valleys but I've watched a
scene the whole time and I am police say
recently wrote a book about it called
Kings a crypto that tells the history of
of Bitcoin into the Krypton industry but
through the vehicle of coinbase just
however they became players and the big
focus is on how Wall Street and Silicon
Valley are coming together yeah so what
was the the impetus for moving from
being a lawyer to a journalist because I
think a lot of people would say there's
not tons and tons of people who go from
that field to journalism but what kinda
was the interest there um
I guess it like writing and that's you
know I like telling stories and writing
and as a lawyer you do a lot of writing
but it's very you know it's it's kind of
Julis it's like writing extend you know
car manuals you know 30 60 page back to
I'm not a lot of fun and also I mean I
think I was working on am once a law
clerk I was working a pharmaceutical
patent trial it's going on for ten days
and it was just like it was just like
ready to like you know shoot myself it
was just so dull same thing day in day
out and then with them with with
journalism you get to talk to everyone
get to I've met everyone in crypto you
get to hear their stories you get to
write something new every day
which is which is a lot of fun and feels
real rewarding yeah that's awesome and
so then how um how did you first hear
about this Satoshi circle right where
people were doing this I feel like
that's a kind of an underground type
thing that they weren't exactly running
advertisements on television for so what
was where'd that come from
uh probably Twitter like everything else
in crypto I just heard about it and then
I reached out to a couple people and I
have to confess how ignorant to us at
the time I you know I'd planned to go I
bought a Bitcoin to go there because I
thought there'd be people selling stuff
like you know muffins or t-shirts or
something and you know I thought that's
what Satoshi Square was and so I you
know bought a Bitcoin from coinbase for
like 70 bucks and I plan to expense it
and you know I'm not happy to say I
forgot to and it's one of those rare
times it turned out well because I yeah
so you know I don't own any other crypto
because I want to keep you know
impartial as a journalist but that was a
bit of good fortune yeah and then so
when you got there what was everyone
doing if they weren't selling muffins
and t-shirts oh they're just kind of
sitting around and talking about Bitcoin
or what was it yeah they were no there
was like Wall Street guys in five
thousand dollar suits coming up with
like stacks of hundreds I'm I'm kidding
and just like buying you know from these
like dreadlock dudes and they all had a
passion for crypto and they all have
like thrown wallets and I mean these
guys were you know really knew the tech
and really knew the economics of it how
they were determining price I don't know
I think they're just checking the
internet and you know the other buying
selling Bitcoin in the open air is kind
of cool and so this is probably what
like 2012-2013 if it was down around 70
bucks somewhere in that time for him yep
good memory 2013 some point in like you
know mayor the summer and there's just
his corner of Union Square in New York
that was every Monday was called Satoshi
Square I mean I think similar things
popped up elsewhere but it was kind of
cool to you know unify was totally
ignorant was kind of cool to take it in
yeah for sure
and then I guess as part of that like
coinbase I think if I remember correctly
2013 or 2014 was it came around so
really it's almost like they were doing
this out of necessity because there
wasn't great us-based infrastructure
to go ahead and buy Bitcoin is that
generally right yeah I mean that's the
thesis I put in the start of my book
Peter tou now the famous investor you
know wrote his book zero to one and he
talks about open secrets you know those
things in retrospect are so obvious like
why don't you start a company to use
your phone to Hale cars you know rather
than relying on taxis why don't we
create a you know internet distributed
system to rent you know spare rooms in
our houses you know Airbnb uber in
retrospect so obviously I know Brian
Armstrong's thesis was like what if we
made Bitcoin easy to buy and there's a
lot of obstacles that both technical
ones but also cultural and to this day I
think a lot of the crypto community
takes pride in how tech-savvy they are
but the reality is most people to start
out like good at that or that interested
in it so making it easy is was critical
I think that's how they did what they
did and both then and now it's also got
a lot of resentment from real you know
what so-called real crypto people who
you know people still font coinbase not
not your coins not your keys and I get
it but the reality is you know nine
percent of people in crypto weren't
gonna get there in the first place most
to make it easy yeah and and I guess in
those early days of crypto you know
you've done tons and tons of work were
you able to actually talk to Brian and
fred and were they made available for
the book or did you have to kind of do
this without their participation no I
was lucky because I mean since I've
covered so I'm covered coinbase since
its inception so I you know known Brian
Armstrong for years and that makes it
sort of easier and then fortunately they
you know for one reason or another they
they decided to play ball you know I
didn't you know this isn't like an you
know authorized biography I mean because
I you know to put it create you know
there's a lot of people talk about a
ship in the book about coinbase and I
relay it I report what I found but I was
lucky to have access to Brian to Fred
Olaf Carlsen we real character really
knows his crypto and it was really
interesting like startups you know a
certain point any big companies kind of
the same the big and bureaucratic and so
on but startups are just the energy and
the personality is really interesting so
it was neat peeling back the curtain of
the early days there yeah and so I guess
let's talk about that right say I think
a lot of people forget especially people
were coming into crypto now you've got
Brian and
Fred as to the co-founders Olaf's
obviously one of the first employees or
I think he might even been the first
employee
these guys have all gone on to kind of
run different things that are leaders in
their specific niches of the crypto
space and so like what were those early
days like as you're talking to them and
talking to others in the space like help
us understand what's going on in the
early days of coinbase yeah I guess what
struck me is how hard these guys worked
I mean I guess that's just the world of
startups but I mean they were really
like working 18 hours a day it was Brian
you know I mean there's a bit of
intrigue at the start because he was a Y
Combinator company and you know Sam
Altman
you know the founder of Y Combinator
told me that their model is they want
co-founders because building startups
too much work on their own but when at
the outset I mean wired reported this
years ago it's a guy named Ben Reeves
for the you know old crypto guy started
blockchain he and Brian entered Y
Combinator as co-founders but right on
the cusp of starting someone at Y
Combinator whispered in Brian's ear hey
you got to cut this guy loose because
there was a ideological division because
Ben Reeves was like we can't you know
have a semi centralized service you know
it's got and then you know but Brian was
like look the whole points making it
easy and we're you know so basically he
booted his co-founder with the
complicity of Y Combinator at the outset
built it up but the reality is you know
he needed someone else and a few months
later Fredersen was goldman sachs trader
who got disillusioned by how
technologically stupid goldman was moved
to the west coast and just met Brian and
read it and then the two of them just
like you know busted their ass building
it all of course and we of course now
runs poly chain he was a freaking
lumberjack I mean he's sort of a
character he was working in the state of
Washington like as a lumberjack and he
was really into Bitcoin and he turned up
in San Francisco and said hey guys can I
work for you and you know that that's
how they started real sort of synergy
there they added a another engineer
named Craig Hamill and then Charlie Lee
who of course is famous for litecoin and
that was the original team and you know
there's something about when you have
people
who meshed like that and work hard
together and that's I think how they
they launched it yeah and I guess it's
really interesting when you think
through not only that small team but but
there's some irony in Brian Armstrong
and Fred coming together giving Fred's
background from Wall Street which is
that there's definitely a ideological
divide like you described where not only
do you get inside of Krypton but like
Krypto is an ideological divide from the
trishul wall street right and so to see
somebody crossover like that so early
and go build infrastructure there did
Fred kind of give any insight into I'm
assuming his former co-workers thought
he was crazy and kind of the classical
story or were they more encouraging and
really want to see him kind of go for
this no he was he was disillusioned
because he was you know in in Goldman
and he was a traitor
but he had a real you know he's got a
real talent for software and obviously
he realized we're you know this was I
think when would this be like yeah
2012-2013 where there would have been
less the floor traders and the culture
of you know those firms is like liars
poker it's you know kind of like big
athletic dudes who you know showed each
other down in a pit whereas you know all
the while you know they the guys who did
build algos were you know coming in but
you know fred was describing how the
goldman people disdained you know the
computerized traders who treated them as
the IT staff and you know he just saw
where the future was going you know in
his words but obviously he's turned out
to be right and so that led him to to
leave and it's funny so apparently his
you know his co-workers were like you
know haha what's that or I don't know if
he knew he's gonna do crypto but when he
got into coinbase he went to his when
his former manager the one guy who did
get tech and was like hey do you want to
buy and early on could coinbase for
$25,000 and you know I wish that guys
sitting very pretty right now yeah and
so there's this famous photo of Brian
Armstrong and I forget where it is but
it's in the early days of coinbase he's
got a coin based shirt on if I remember
correctly it's basically at like a job
fair or some sort of event and he's
literally like handing out t-shirts and
I remember asking somebody about it
and I don't want to say who it is but
they basically like yeah people forget
that at one point
Quinn base didn't take off at first and
there was talk of potentially even like
should they shut it down
Rekha's actually wasn't working and then
it kind of really took off and so kind
of how when you were writing the book
like how did you think about the various
phases of the company and kind of that
you know hard work overlaid with this
just a psychological toll it takes on a
founder working on something that not
only is just hard to build a company but
it's also in this industry that kind of
sort of existed but but not a lot of
people really recognized it you know in
2014 and things like that yeah and
that's a great point pom cuz I mean that
startup life you know most of them fail
but they were in a whole industry you
know you do you know if the whole
industry was gonna make it so that's
even more existential yeah I mean you
know it's you know that the peaks and
valleys of crypto 2013 it went on you
know a bit of a run and yeah camera
where the prices got up to you but then
it you know collapsed entirely again
like it looks like that's where it sort
of nudged a thousand bucks you know in
the early early days it went from thirty
bucks to two but in the next uptick I
think was 2013 hit almost a thousand and
then the floor fell out and yeah talking
there I mean they you know they had
their venture funding by then so they
could write it out but I do know in the
first group to winter in 2014 people
confided me that they drew up a plan to
you know to can 40% of their staff
because they always want to keep it to
year run away and then you know just as
happens ever so often then the prices
started ticking up again and they were
able to hold on so it's you know so
series of events like that and I think
it's true to this day you know you'll
have these you know massive frenzies of
trading and all the exchanges you know
make a bunch of money and then things go
really quiet and you know things shut
down things get acquired people get laid
off but you know here we are again yeah
another player that uh that came from
coinbase and now is gonna do other
really impressive things is Adam White
and I know that there's some stories
about Adam in in the book so maybe kind
of share one or two of the really
interesting things that that Adam went
through while working at coinbase yeah I
mean Adam White's one of the good guys
in crypto you know he's just a you know
really stand-up dude I think yesterd has
no enemies worked really
interesting story too I mean he was a
you know a fighter you know he's in the
a fighter pilot in the UM in the Air
Force and you know so he served his
country and then went to come back to
Harvard Business School took him too you
know and he's so humble he admitted it
took him two tries to get in he got
rejected he you know wrote and rewrote
his application got in and around them
he got into Bitcoin and it's sort of
funny that he you know he tried to write
about this at Harvard Business School
and they're like no no no this is friend
just as flaky so and you know this is
complete self-promotion I think it's
awesome the my books coming up in print
it's out an audio right now but it'll be
out in print in December and the
publisher is Harvard Business Review so
this sort of shows how how far things
come but but you know Adam yeah he's so
he was basically the sales guy he you
know he bust his asked to go and get
people to sign up to take you know
merchants you know and his challenge was
Fredersen told him you know sign up like
you know ten billion dollar companies
and he did which is amazing but
unfortunately you know as we learned you
know that never was bitcoins game you
know because remember there was his time
where everyone thought oh and people are
gonna pay with Bitcoin merchants want
Bitcoin and not all these people up but
you know then obviously not much came of
that well my favorite story with Adam is
some later in the game and Streb around
I think
2016 around there when things were taken
off Bryan Armstrong coinbase centum is
an emissary to New York you know cuz
he's kind of like walking down through
you know he looks the part he looks like
a banker and he's like go get some of
these like old school you know firms on
board so he gets a meeting with Cantor
Fitzgerald which you know is sort of as
like classic Wall Street as you can get
you know we're talking like scotch and
three-peat suits and steak houses and
you know so he goes to me he gets the
meeting and he shows up on his own and
the CEO of Cantor Fitzgerald comes with
like 10 guys and Adam has no tie on and
his title was like general manager and
they started mocking him saying like
what's the general manager you're gonna
get my coffee and he basically got left
out of the room you know and I think
that's less reflection of Adam than it
is just the prejudice of Wall Street
not only against crypto but against West
Coast culture you know and that's
something I think
you know the crypt of communities
reconciling with right now you know
Silicon Valley and Wall Street are very
different places are coming together but
you know just look how people dress in
the valley look of the dress in Wall
Street and you know culture is a big
part of companies to be part of
industries and that's what we're seeing
right now yeah it's really interesting
kind of that difference in culture
specifically between those two places
you mentioned the dress but but I think
also in kind of way that companies are
built right you know Wall Street very
kind of fundamentally driven they want
to see cash flow and all that
fundamental analysis in Silicon Valley
it's very binary hey we know that you
know some high percentage these comes
you're going out of business but the
ones that make it are gonna be
incredibly valuable and I see it in a
day to day right I mean literally you
will see kind of the Silicon Valley
mindset but it's overlaid with your
building in the financial industry right
for all intents and purposes and so
there's this undercurrent of the Wall
Street way if you will I mean in the
book as you're writing it like I'm
assuming you saw that clash over and
over and over again and it wasn't just
kind of out of white going into Cantor
and getting you know berated but but
were there other situations where you
kind of saw that come to a head as
coinbase was being built
oh yeah many times I mean you know they
you know move move fast and break things
ethos of the valley
you know that's well and good but it
doesn't work in most industries and you
know we're talking about the country's
banking system you can't play that way
and you know that affected you in sort
of the cultural clashes with regulators
but also from an instant infrastructure
point of view you know I'm you know
above my paygrade here but you know the
tools that used to build it you know
it's like um you know it's the famous
database thing you know MongoDB and
tools like that that are the kind of go
to building blocks for spinning up an
app and Silicon Valley just are not
strong enough to you know withstand like
you know billions of financial
transactions so you know that the tech
stack like in 2017 for coinbase almost
came crumbling down because they built
it on Silicon Valley architecture and
you know again you know prompt you and
you know probably your crowd knows this
stuff better than me but the the
technological infrastructure you need to
build something like JPMorgan it's got
to be really solid and capable of
so throughput and you know coinbase got
burned in late 2017 because their
infrastructure almost fell down and so
that's you know that's not so much a
cultural thing but it kind of is the
approaches to how you build Silicon
Valley you build fast you stand up you
pivot your experiment but you know when
you're talking about you know the wall
street you you gotta build you know very
deliberately and make it to last for
sure
and I guess it's not only just Silicon
Valley versus Wall Street right I know
another kind of theme of crypto is it's
much more global than most industries
right I've got kind of mental framework
where a lot of companies especially
technology wise they were built in the
United States previously they would
penetrate the US market and then there
was almost like a board meeting it was
okay you know this year is our global
expansion right then they would kind of
go out globally now these companies are
being built on one not even being based
in New York or San Francisco but also on
top of that they're global on day one
right they they don't kind of have this
geographic region by geographic region
kind of you know rollout plan if you
will and so kind of how do you think
that plays into coinbase being based in
San Francisco but the industry being
much more decentralized to some degree
yeah that's a really great question
because you know you're right typically
you know you build here and then you go
market by market but when you've got you
know people like cz who stood up finance
in a few months and you know he you know
he runs circles around coinbase
and that's not entirely coinbase his
fault but you know so much of the crypto
industries fate is determined by
regulation and you know in the u.s. you
know it's it's it's been pretty
heavy-handed and so coinbase had to make
a choice to win the u.s. to win the
world but it also made them complacent
because i think you know there is a bit
of an American arrogance talk to some
sources in the book but even when
coinbase went to China and Asia you know
they were you know talking to people who
built in in Asia they thought like Brian
and Fred were extremely arrogant they're
like look you wanna you know you want to
compete come you know come come come try
win in you know China and Japan you know
before you tell us what to do so that's
I think really interesting and then but
the reality now is you know by Nantz
you know they done amazing things but
you know if you're hopscotch
from Malta to Hong Kong to wherever they
are now last I heard cz was planning to
go to international waters and run the
whole thing from a yacht you know that's
it's I think it's cool but you know and
if you're gonna operate me unless you
know as much as crypto folks like being
Cowboys you can't blow off you know the
Treasury Department you can't blow off
the IRS so you know that could hurt
America you know from a competitive
point of view in the long term but
that's reality that you know that
startups and crypto companies face you
know you you gotta play the game
do you think that that makes an argument
that the regulators or the regulations
should change or there should be some
kind of maybe even not like a full
change but like a sandbox where
innovation can be tried or or something
done from a regulation standpoint that
allows for the u.s. to not fall behind
from an innovation standpoint or do you
feel like it's just hey they're so true
it's a kind of that way that's never
gonna change and US comes just gonna
have to figure out how to how to compete
with with their hands can't hide behind
it back in some regard yeah I mean I
don't know I think you know you know you
and probably a lot of your audience are
closer to those questions than me but as
a reporter watching this I certainly do
feel that the American crypto companies
are being hampered it's improving a bit
I mean I think the regime's you know
trying to set up a sandbox regime in
Wyoming which sounds great Brian Brooks
coin basis former lawyer you know
becoming you know the you know
controller of the currency that's
promising but also I think people
underestimate the the lobbying clout of
you know of the banking industry in DC
you know if they want to shut something
down they will so you know but
fortunately as much as you know I'm
because I know I've got a piece in the
book but Brian arm I'm going to DC
because they tried to get him on the
lobbying circuit he hated it you know
he's like you know he told someone I
think that Democrats senators and ass
and I can't stand any of this because
Silicon Valley guys they want to build
they don't want to do that but you know
that the industry's got to grow up and
that's just kind of how American
capitalism works for better or worse so
you know I think as as the industry gets
more entrenched they're they're lobbying
in Washington shops will get better I
mean that's what Google and Facebook did
once upon time they refused to go to
Washington now they're there again for
better or worse you know that's just how
the American game is played
yeah so coinbase was obviously a Bitcoin
only for a long time right and then
started to add other assets anything
that was memorable as people kind of
talked about the strategy evolving from
Bitcoin only to other assets and now
they're even doing things around staking
and custody and kind of moving outside
of just help you buy Bitcoin which
sounds like that was the original
mission kind of any takeaways there yeah
I mean Quinn base was caught flat-footed
I mean that's part of these they got so
beat by finance for a while and you know
sir reason people like Olaf and
Fredersen left the company they want to
spread their wings and there's a period
in 2015-16 where this Bitcoin got so
bitter between the block size debate you
know remember people wanted to expand it
to two megabytes and all that and so
much the energy was consumed in politics
and backstabbing and fighting that
meanwhile all that was going on in
Bitcoin world and then what vitalik was
building you know it was it seemed
suddenly very positive you know it seems
you know full of potential so you know
Fred wrote us through a famous blog post
saying hey this is the future and he
left to pursue it and coin based his
drag defeat adding a theory I'm adding
anything part of that was from right for
regulatory reasons to be fair but part
of it was inertia
they got complacent and then it happened
again when finance started adding every
token Under the Sun you know they there
was a talk in coinbase people were
advocating look let's split the company
into you know we'll have an
international holding company that can
go plan you know and all those markets
do the crazy stuff an American company
which they probably should have done but
then part of it was cultural I mean Olaf
was saying you know they had such a good
2017 they're like oh what should we do
to maximize her tax advantage rather
than building you know they lost touch
with the pulse of the crypto community
and people were like hey let's add
dogecoin which would have been easy lift
and look well we don't know about the
you know ROI on that and you know so but
that's when they brought Balaji in and
he you know bloody stern Avastin is
pretty famous for a variety of reasons
in crypto world and he really injected
some energy and was just like you know
hell-bent on atom tokens and that's I
think how they managed to get their ass
in gear again yeah so maybe talk a
little bit more
Balaji came into the earn comm
acquisition
and became the CTO I recently had a mana
for an episode and we spent almost zero
time talking about coinbase and spent
most of the time talking about all the
crazy powerful ideas he has but in terms
of that acquisition if I remember
correctly that was the first big
acquisition that they did where it was
you know kind of a nine figure some
attached to it reportedly was that
specifically for kind of a change in
strategy or what was kind of the driving
force behind rather than building
everything internally to go out and buy
a company like that blood she's a hard
figure to report on and we met him a
couple times he's incredibly polarizing
and divisive however what everyone
agrees with is he's a genius he's one of
the smartest people in crypto and in
general so the account of you know
getting earned comm you know some people
related to me that it was a dog of a
company and since andreessen horowitz
had a big stake in that and coinbase was
a way to solve that problem a lot of
people whispered in my ear that the
official price you know the nine figures
whatever it was wasn't actually true but
it was to satisfy blood she's ego you
know I I don't take a position on that
that's a lot of people whisper in my ear
however blood she did do the job in
really kind of changing up the culture
at coinbase you know and it's - well the
downside was it resulted in the Civil
War I mean he pushed at him white out he
pushed a lot of people out you know as
someone called him coin bases first
brilliant [ __ ] other people said he
would win survivor you know I don't take
a position on itis there no blood she
well enough I do think he's got
formidable intelligence that's for sure
and then ultimately it became a showdown
in coin based between Asif her G their
you know Co oh and president for a while
who was making the company more
corporate and so you know which had to
be done a SIF did a lot of good things
he sort of made it into a mature company
but at the same time the rank and file
and coinbase didn't like him because he
wasn't a real crypto guy and they all
worship Balaji because blood she could
code he need tokens he knew the scene he
was of it so you know and ultimately I
came to a head where this you know kind
of a big bloody count and
couldn't has lost a lot of people and I
think it forced Bryan Armstrong to come
in and lead because you know Bryan does
not like conflicts but sometimes if your
lieutenants are in a shooting war you
got to step in and do something I'm the
final straw was I guess ass if asked
Bryant report to him on product Bryan
owns the majority of the company and as
a CEO and that was a bridge too far and
so that's when you know he got pushed
out and then balázs he on his one-year
vesting period was just he pieced out
that was that yeah I Asif obviously used
to run TD Ameritrade right so kind of
came from a much more kind of Wall
Street type background and I guess part
of this is not even just coin based but
most companies as they go through what I
was called growing pains right there's
positives negatives and you're trying to
build something that's worth billions
and billions of dollars right so
obviously it's going to be hard to do
would you say that most people kind of
understand that it was important to have
that period where bla she came in and
had an impact it was important to have
the period where Asif came in and had an
impact and like those moments although
may be painful at the time have kind of
built coinbase and the culture has into
today or do you feel like there's kind
of certain points in the history of
coinbase
where those that are left point back and
say hey we wish we could have skipped
over certain periods where we wouldn't
have made certain decisions in the past
that we actually ended up making now I
think that's a good way to look at the
bigger picture I mean I think people in
a start-up going through something like
that think they're the only one has
happened to but even if you step back
and he's like look you know the reality
in the valley is a company gets that big
that quickly the executive team is gonna
turn over two or three times you know so
you're gonna have moments like this and
then you've had the hidden hand of
Andreessen the whole way to you know I
mean I think Chris Dixon and Fred Wilson
of you know Union Square Ventures of and
Barry Schulman you know you got these
real smart you know
veterans who've been kind of you know
the hidden hand shaping the path so you
know I think while it makes a good
newspaper coffee and you know salacious
book gossip I don't know if it's that
different from what goes on that you
know any tech successful tech company
that skills quickly yeah elaborate a
little bit more on the venture
capitalist right you just
three names that are at firms that have
now become very well known not only one
for just investing in general but
obviously for crypto specifically how do
you think about their impact on coinbase
right I'm assuming coinbase couldn't
become coin based without them but but
how involved are they or were they in
any kind of insight there as to whether
involvement yeah I mean I think they've
had a you know huge hand in guiding it
you know Marc Andreessen Chris Dix and
Fred Wilson they're kind of the rabbi's
behind the scenes you know that doesn't
take you know I don't mean to diminish
credit to Brian and Fred who you know
busted they're asked to build the
company but it's kind of um you know
symbiotic in the sense that you know for
the crypto industry Quinn base is too
big to fail I mean if coinbase collapsed
I think you know it would set crypto
back a decade so I think you know that's
why maybe it's got more attention or
from the VCS than other firms you know
I'm not saying you know coinbase is the
best or the only firm Kraken does good
things finance has been amazing you know
you know even Gemini there's seen a lot
of good crypto players out there but you
know they if you want to put the face of
crypto out there it's coinbase
and you know if coinbase went south I
think the ripple effects would be
disastrous for the industry yeah and
when you say go south is that from a
business model standpoint is that more
of like a custody security hack type
standpoint maybe it's both like how do
you think about the the downside case or
the risk that's associated with a
company like coin base being as big as
it is well I mean I think they're you
know probably safe by now I mean and the
final tree up from a book could talk
about a clandestine meeting between
Brian Armstrong and JP Morgan's CEO
Jamie Dimon and I why do I love this so
much is of course Dimon is you know
bitcoins most famous antagonists you
know he's called it you know every name
in the book a fraud and insulted it then
meanwhile he's taking the secret meeting
with Brian Armstrong you know in the you
know in in JP Morgan's Manhattan
headquarters so you know I think that's
that sort of shows that you know
coinbase is here to stay
in terms of moments that could have sunk
them you know fatal hack you know the
industry barely survived
lux something that that befell coinbase
because you had to remember most
American crypto owners that's what they
know crypto is I mean I think people
come on your show the people who are
running the funds and building it
they're all like you know that's child's
play but for most Americans or you know
most a lot of other consumers in the
world that's our touchstone you know so
if there's a disastrous packet coinbase
it would sink them could still happen i
guess but i do recount from a book and
early Hackney and coinbase alexei has
never been hacked that's not true
in the early stage when there's just
five of them one of their vendors got in
and got into the hot wallet and quickly
stole $250,000 and after that they
appointed ASIS issued only um
custom Chromebooks to anyone working
with them and tighten their security and
then also um forgive me I can't remem
the guys name starts with a you know
he's a very famous figure in crypto
who's you know and topless and thought
was something like that
Andreas Antonopoulos yep thank you yep
they hired him to go and test their cold
storage and to do a complete audit of to
make sure every Bitcoin they had was
indeed there you know because remember
would happen with Mount Cox you know car
plus was sitting there he thought he had
it now when I looked it wasn't there so
and thoughtless verified it was there so
I think getting by that I think getting
through the IRS audit and you know so I
think that's and then your other
existential point was when Silicon
Valley Bank gave them the boot which is
very bad because Fedderson ill-advisedly
put up a PowerPoint explaining how
Bitcoin you know was could skirt
sanctions
he wasn't advising it and you know he's
kind of right you know because it's
decentralized but you don't go around
you know making presentations like that
and Silicon Valley Bank finally had
enough and booted them and that's a big
deal you know they you know I know it
really pissed off Chris Dixon and stuff
and at least they gave him a six month
grace period to find another banker but
if that that could have sunk them to but
I think at this point you know coinbase
is they might lose market share you know
they might someone else might come along
but I think they've really kind of
become the face of the industry yeah and
so you mentioned Brian and Jamie Dimon
meeting we recently saw in the news that
JP Morgan is now banking both coinbase
and Gemini
is that part that kind of leading to
that or was there other conversation
that you're aware of as part of I love
the word clandestine that you use yeah
it's funny because you know I learned it
happen and there everyone's like you
know it's trying to get you know JP
Morgan to confirm and then you know it's
certainly skittish about it and stuff
yeah I think cuz Brian did a East Coast
- Cooper met with Lloyd Blankfein of
Goldman Sachs and Jamie Dimon and I
think it was both sort of a you know
he's you know being an Avenger Ella Cole
for a crypto but also I think he wants
to learn from these guys who whatever
you think of the traditional finance
industry I mean Blankman and diamond are
formidable financial executives and I
think it was a little bit you know -
come sit at their feet learn what they
have to say you know and no doubt that
probably was the first step to lay the
groundwork for what was reported last
week of you know JP JP Morgan taking on
coin basis the banking customer yeah
that's awesome
so let's look forward obviously coinbase
today and I pressured caveat this entire
conversation we have some exposure to
coinbase financially we're not direct
investors in the company but basically
we've invested in somebody who's
invested in the company but where do
they go from here right in terms of that
it's an 8 plus billion dollar company
based on public reports but do they
continue to stay private forever do they
have aspirations to go public
do they tokenize the company's equity I
think what time Brian said something
about you know that would be like the
most coin based thing to do I'm kind of
what's the conversation around the
company from that standpoint you know
insiders told me the plan was to go
public this year but you know like
everything else then pandemic you know
life is on hold um you know but unlike
so many other unicorns I mean they are
you know profitable most quarters so
they can and I think you put your finger
on it the question is not you know if or
when it's how and I talked to Fredersen
recently and you know ask them this like
what's it gonna look like are you gonna
do a blockchain token and he said yeah
I'd be pretty boring if we just did a
conventional Nasdaq IPO and I think
there's so many people because they are
you know a lot of people hate coinbase
but you know they're they're the
industry leader they're the standard
bearer for the industry so I think could
be very brutally disappointing if
just did something boring so I think
it's just how much you know how quickly
they can have the regulatory ducks in a
row and you know what I hear in the
companies they want to do some hybrid
listing of you know they'll float some
shares like normal but also put a bunch
of those on a token and do you know
these sort of a ICO meets IPO and I
can't wait to see the details and that's
what they hope to do but who knows I
mean maybe their investors will get
impatient and just push them out the
door but I think the crypto world is
really hoping for a you know a coin base
token yeah and it's interesting too
because I wonder if there's a day where
we see a coin base equity token trading
on coin base right which kind of leads
to the question of they historically
have listed assets that are not
securities and I think that's you know
as you mentioned kind of part of that
underwriting process and really kind of
trying to stand the right side of the
regulator's does the company eventually
end up listing kind of commodities
currencies in securities all in this
digital format all in one location or
how do you think that kind of plays out
basically covers you had yeah you're
you're that's prescient I mean I think
you're looking into the future and
that's what the future is gonna be you
know I think we're gonna see Nike and
Apple stock and other equities you know
traded as tokens because it just makes
so much sense it's so much more
efficient it's more secure who will be
doing that I don't know possibly
coinbase but we could also see you know
the big broker we could see
IntercontinentalExchange trying to buy
jam and ir coinbase and you know this
see a period where we have you know
hybrid share listings for a while but I
think no doubt you know I you know I
don't know what your guess is I'd say
maybe within ten years we'll see that
yeah look III personal my personal
opinion is that we will see stocks bonds
currencies in commodities all digitized
right kind the technology layer will be
the same and it just generally makes
sense we're kind of seeing this right if
you take some of the companies we see
that are focused on like millennial
investing and things like that they're
trying to put various asset classes
together on the same platform that's a
little bit different but but still
directionally getting towards where you
could buy Bitcoin buy a stock or buy
something else on one location
it just seems that's the way the future
is gonna play out but I don't know right
yeah I mean technologies
you know remember we had the internet
when we realized things were gonna go
digital you know and they logically
should have the next year in some
industries it took them 20 years and you
know but I just can't see going
backwards this stuff just makes so much
sense but who's gonna do it I don't know
we'll we'll coinbase morph into become
the you know New York Stock Exchange the
future will they get acquired you know
and then also the other people big in
this game is you know Facebook with your
Libra token you know I think it's noble
at Apple and Amazon we're gonna start
tokenizing stuff - you know there's
government central banks it's it's kind
of a jump ball out there but I think
you're absolutely right all this is
going to happen but who's gonna pull it
off first I don't know yeah I think it
was 2017 maybe I tweeted and I said look
you know within the next 24 months we're
gonna get large companies start to issue
these tokens and my guess was actually
Tesla and Amazon Tesla having like some
sort of energy credit for the the grid
right so you actually have some
incentive mechanism that that's used
there and then Amazon just from the idea
that a gift card is basically a token
right I mean yeah it's a different
technology form factor and so you can
easily see kind of this happening but I
do think that it's happened slower than
people have thought right it was kind of
like in 17 everything will be who's
gonna happen you know within 24 months
now it's probably pushed out a little
ways well I mean if someone's gonna
build the interface the problem with it
I don't want to know and salt the crypto
community but I think they're so in love
with their own technology their own
culture there's been a lag in building
you know I mean even with dphi stuff I
try to cover it and I mean this
theoretically it's so cool but I mean
you want me to get it you know browser
add-on and meta masks and all the rest
of it and I mean give me a break this
stuff has got to be you know an app it's
got to be easy to use as any other app
on my phone and that's where I think the
big corporates could have a role I think
Amazon you know Tesla yes given their
unique corporate culture could do that
but you know I mean we need those user
interfaces and it's just seems a lot of
crypto sometimes this insider
compressing each other with who can
build the most you know kind of out
there technically sophisticated products
and we got to remember you know most
people this stuff is just too hard you
got to build it so it's accessible the
UI is so crucial and
I think you got to build a plumbing
first and that's what's going on but you
know who's gonna crack the code and make
this mainstream accessible I don't know
could be coinbase could be Tesla could
be Amazon could be Apple could be
Facebook or some income and some startup
out there who's gonna solve this all but
I can't wait to see how it turns out
yeah I mean look corn based gemenon I
think part of what's made those
companies so successful writers they
basically made it look very similar to
other brokerage type products right and
so if you're if you're used to kind of
buying financial assets on a platform
you now can do it here and they make it
look and feel very user friendly but
then you also have things like cash app
right that are just you know stupid
simple and they're kind of pulling other
people in I wonder what other trends I'm
kind of going with in Quinn base to
finish up and you've covered you know
crypto for a while now and obviously
seen everything from the early stays to
now what are the other trends that are
interesting to you you mention defy but
are there other things that it just kind
of stick out to you or that you're
paying attention to Justin said you
mentioned Cash Shop Square a Sutton to a
VC recently you just described as a
beast and Dorsey's interest in crypto
and the infrastructure they're building
it's subtle but I mean they've got a
giant banking network you know so they
there wants to watch that would be
really neat if they push the crypto ball
forward I could see them doing that for
sure you know otherwise I think the
thing to watch right now is what comes
out of the crisis we've seen with the
you know attempts to deliver funds you
know to to businesses you know and
within the last crisis in 2008-2009
you know we saw legislation that enabled
the whole fin tech industry to take off
the PayPal's and things like that
so I'm watching to see if the lawmakers
are smart enough to do something to to
facilitate how things are going to
change you know I think the way we pay
is changing you know like I'm Canadian
I'm surprised that the u.s. still
doesn't you know have contactless
payments you know Canada's had that for
years you know everywhere else
Asia's miles ahead and you know it might
take this health crisis to get people to
stop swiping credit cards you know so
I'm curious a lot of the innovations in
us the world is going to come into
America and I'm always surprised about
how cultural payment is just you know
people pay very differently in norther
Europe and in Asia and Canada and
America so you know and obviously
kryptos gonna have a role to play in
that as well
I'm watching Facebook entry you know
closely because I think that that notion
of I know a lot of people hate it
because it's centralized is not real
crypto that's true
but I think the more people get familiar
with this with tokens with you know
fungible wallets you know let's just get
everyone on a platform and then educate
them about you know having their own
hardware wallet and stuff so sorry
that's kind of a stream-of-consciousness
answer but that's some of the things I'm
looking at and finally central bank's
too you know I think you know are they
going to you know we're gonna see you
know what's is China gonna pull this off
can you do it without turning to a
surveillance mechanism I think that's
gonna be a big story in the next couple
years so the only thing I'm gonna
correct you on is Jack if you listen to
this is scoffing because he would say
he's in a Bitcoin not crypto but I'd
other than that I definitely agree that
they specifically have this unique place
in the market where they've got the
connectivity to kind of a legacy system
and then when you've got the the leader
of the company who is so kind of
hell-bent on Bitcoin and in kind of its
future prospects that you know you just
don't see that anywhere else right yeah
what if you strapped it to you know to
Twitter why not go in a payment network
and us some of the media drives me crazy
that Apple and Google with Chrome and
Safari don't build in a crypto token so
that you come across well my articles
there's a paywall what if there's a
little button you could just say you
know yeah pay a buck you know and use
crypto tokens to do that I mean the
technology you know it's just it's it's
so obviously you know that it would be
useful to deploy it this way you know
it's just someone's gonna step up and
lead maybe it's Jack maybe it's
Zuckerberg you know maybe it's Brian
Armstrong but you know it's gonna happen
I don't know house in but it's gonna
happen yeah I guess what are the areas
those everything you mentioned on the
trend side is very kind of positive
looking what are the areas where you say
other than the user experience these are
the big obstacles that crypto has to
overcome in the next kind of five to ten
years I think they got to build
something someone needs I mean it's a
reporter I mean you know these pitches I
get like these you know I don't mean to
you know pick on some companies but like
Definity raised a hundred million
dollars for welcome
ughter that's gonna change everything
you know it's like okay where is it and
I think it's just a structural model a
traditional startup you've gotta like
build you got to get customers you got
to get revenue you gotta scrape to get
your series a and your shows be the
crypto models flawed because it's like
okay here's a hundred million dollars
you know go build it and guess what a
lot of these people it's a lot more fun
to go and like fly around the world and
go to conferences and do stuff like that
than to grind you know because it's
there's not enough pressure to you know
to build the stuff so I think the
incentive model within crypto is very
flawed but you know we'll we'll see what
happens so I think that's gonna be a
threat to it I think there's you know
just you know they've got us people have
got to start speaking plain English you
know you know polka dot and defending
all this is really interesting
theoretically and I'm in the world so I
kind of appreciate it but you know
they've got to make this stuff relatable
to ordinary people yeah today's a great
a great point we're kin now we're can
people go find the book if they want to
read more about it well thanks for
asking Pompeii I mean you know it's just
if you want to learn about coinbase and
crypto I think it'll have you covered
but also you know it's it's a great
story I think there's a lot of gossip I
tell it narrative style so you know
it'll should fly by if you go to Amazon
audible and Google kings of crypto you
can get it they've got the exclusive
rights for that for a few more months
and you can pre-order from harvest
Harvard Business Review again to search
kings of crypto and you can order it up
that way so um yeah you know I hope
people do because it's it's a good story
and there's a lot of gossip in there
about two people you might know so
that's awesome before I let you go I
always ask everyone two questions and
then you get to ask me one to finish up
what is the most important book you've
ever read oh my goodness can you ask me
the second one and I'll get back to you
on that second was not much easier
aliens believer or non-believer
that's easy non-believer I love
astronomy I love the Stars no aliens out
there no wait wait you gotta explain
that why no aliens and they're one of
you may be the fifth person ever to say
no aliens
we wouldn't heard from them okay yeah
let's see most important book I've read
and I'm probably supposed to say this in
business
but I love fiction so probably crime and
punishment it's just the best detective
story it's the best piece of Russian
literature ever written and it's just
exploring people's motives Souls you
know life death God atheism it's all in
there so uh you know if you're stuck at
home in the pandemic read crime and
punishment so I have not read that but I
did read bill Browder's book it is read
I'm gonna forget the name now it is read
I forget but bill Browder is the guy who
he's an American investor and he went to
Russia and a red notices name and they
issue a red notice for him it's this
whole kind of crime and drama book and
killing his lawyer and doing all crazy
stuff and I've heard a bunch but I've
never read the fiction and so I wonder
how how accurate the fiction and the the
nonfiction line up there that sounds
really good I did think of a business
book something most important why I want
to read by listen to it recently a shoe
dog by Phil Knight of Nike great book
you want to hear a guy struggling to
build a company and just the you know
the footwear industry more interesting
than you can possibly imagine so if you
want a good business book pick up shoe
dog it's an old one but a good one
I always say that he made the right
decision not calling it Blue Ribbon
write something about Nike just sounds
better what one question do you have for
me to to wrap this up okay how about the
future of media it's it's it's grim out
there who's gonna save media the
Atlantic just laid a bunch of people off
BuzzFeed's laying people off you know
how does a tiss the media business fix
its business model so we you know so we
can we can stay solvent
yeah so I think there's two paths that
are interesting I don't know necessarily
if they're these are the magic bullets
because I think that there's in the
legacy media world you're gonna see some
actually get stronger right while some
fail and that's just the nature of kind
of consolidation and things like that
but the two new paths that are really
interesting to me one is kind of the sub
stack model where you say look people
are going to subscribe to other people
the market subscriber the publication
itself and so you'll see that kind of
continue to get built out I think we'll
continue to see
journalists leave and can I just say
look I want to break what I want to
write and I be all kinds of weird stuff
not fitting under one publication so you
know support me so see how that plays
out
but then the other thing that I'm really
interested in is kind of these very
small what I call internet first media
companies right and so this is people
who are doing this right now are people
like Tim pool or if you look at somebody
like a David Pakman or you or you see
people like was his name Ben Rubin right
and all of these people what they
basically have done is they've recreated
what it would be a traditional media
company that has you know tens of it's
not hundreds of employees and it's like
them and a staff of four or five right
Joe Rogan's another example right now
Joe's doing video and audio but it
wouldn't be hard to see somebody in Joe
Rogan's position just say hey look we're
gonna hire one person to you know crate
show notes and transcripts and put that
online and we start to see that you
start to say like the me organizations
are gonna have the same disruption
happen that you've seen in every other
sector through technology the big
question is just can they see it coming
right so like New York Times is kind of
notorious one that you know they've
adopted some of this stuff and they're
benefiting obviously fortunes got their
subscription services and and they're
kind of getting behind some of this and
so I think that's really gonna
ultimately depend like who wins and who
does and it's just you know who's awake
or right who's asleep at the wheel yeah
you know so it'll be interesting to
watch but I also don't think it's gonna
happen overnight right I think a lot of
people think like tomorrow all these
media companies are gonna fail I get
maybe but it's more likely that it's
kind of a slow death than it is just you
know everyone goes in a business all at
once
yeah that's the Stute I mean yeah
technology sort of determined so much
and media likes to think it's exempt but
it's it's gonna shape our future so all
right well pom thanks very much real
pleasure to be on your show absolutely
listen Jeff I really appreciate it we'll
talk soon take care